winter is coming and more smoothly than
it did last time second son's season 3
episode 8 I kind of hated the last
episode because of not only the emphasis
on romantic interest but a complete
overload of them however the way that
this following episode is panned out
really does prove to me that what they
did with the bear and the maiden fair
was to cram all of the heavy romance up
into one episode so for someone like me
who didn't enjoy that stuff it is like
ripping off a band-aid it hurt at the
time but it's done and we can move on
now as we've gotten from time to time
this is again largely a setup episode
but it still feels like it's moving
forward much more than those first two
episodes of the season worth so I'm
completely fine with that some
interesting things going on at King's
Landing here Sansa turns up and I didn't
hate her I still don't really like her
as a character but I like the situation
she's now been put in and I think that
situation can potentially help develop
her into somebody that I actually
enjoyed being on screen it's a little
sad watching Tyrion reeling so much from
the stuff going on around him what's
always been fun about him is how he
turned stuff who is advantaging always
feels like he's still on top he's really
been kicked down in this season and it's
interesting but I kind of feel bad for
the guy you may remember i mentioned
Joffrey had become slightly more dynamic
in the wake of stuff that happened at
the end of season 2 in that he seemed to
realize his throne was not as firm as he
thought it was well that's gone he's got
his confidence back which means he's a
full-on dick now which makes him less
dynamic and just annoying then again he
needs to continue to be not only a bad
King but a bad person because a big part
of what's perpetuating all this stuff
going on is how bad he is I mean his
father was a bad King but he was an okay
person this kid room and it's important
for the story that he stayed that way
more or less Tywin Lannister still
pulling everybody's strings and just how
effortlessly this guy is in control of
pretty much the entire world of King's
Landing is really impressive I'm
continuing to find the lady Melisandre
the woman in red increasingly
interesting she's gotten more death to
her now than she ever when she was first
showing up and that
not going away in fact it's building up
a bit more over time we get the return
of Davos The Onion Knight who hasn't had
a lot to do this season but he's always
just a joy to have on screen whenever
he's there one of the things I really
like about this episode is it's a very
good illustration about how the show
balances both epically huge figures and
relatively smaller ones who are still
important in the big scheme of things
cuz you're obviously you're dealing with
kings and Generals and noble families
but you know what we get a lot of really
cool moments and moments for smaller
characters to shine characters like
Gendry like Sam well who I had always
seemed like a bit of a tag on that to me
up to this point but it gets some real
nice moments to shine here the stuff
going on with dinero's continues to be
an absolute highlight at this point a
lot of what the show has been about
overall has been delaying her returning
to Westeros for as long as possible
because obviously when she gets around
to actually showing up on that continent
again it's going to change everything so
the story has really been about delaying
her and giving her obstacles to keep her
from getting there and there were times
on the second season especially where it
felt like very forced stumbling blocks
and forced delays now it's while she's
not just rolling on through she still
got obstacles to overcome where she is
you've got a pretty clear trajectory and
she's definitely building towards her
move to reclaim the throne and I'm
getting really excited for her and where
she's going to be going not too much to
nitpick about this episode really all
the stuff that has been really bothering
me this season it is pretty much absent
totally if I wasn't coming off of an
episode that I had so many issues with
as the bear and the maiden fair then
maybe there would be little things I've
been nitpicking at this but at this
point it's just such a relief versus the
one I had to watch before this that I
just love this and I and I am so excited
to see the last two episodes of the
season so here's a question for you
there's obviously a lot of competing
interest for the Iron Throne who do you
think actually deserves to sit on that
damn thing leave something down in the
comments let's talk about it and until
next time this council is adjourned